precision medicine is changing the way
we understand diagnose and treat cancer
the transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data from patients
animal models and large-scale cell line
experiments
in this program we will explore how such
high throughput data can be analyzed
to study the genomic background of
cancer we will see
how to study omics data that describes
the basic biology associated with cancer
onset
development and outcomes and we'll see
how large-scale data sets collected from
clinical trials provide an opportunity
to better understand this condition
and improve the precision of clinical
oncology
we will break down the complexities of
tumor development
and the role of tumor microenvironment
we will also speak about
the dna genes and rna transcription
and see how these elements are studied
using next generation sequencing data
we will learn about the basic and
translational research in oncology
where patient-derived cell lines
xenograft models
and clinical trials offer a rich
collection of data to inform diagnosis
and treatment of cancer in patients
the recent growth in high throughput
sequencing of cancer genomes and
transcriptomes has produced
a big data problem that precludes many
cancer biologists and oncologists from
gleaning knowledge from these data
regarding the nature of malignant
processes and
identifying the relationship between
tumor genomic profiles
and treatment response that's why we
will learn about these data types
find them on repositories like the ncbi
and see how to efficiently process and
analyze such data
together we will map visualize and
detect significant changes in dna
sequences
using a reference genome and paired
tumor and normal samples
we will use rna-seq analysis to run a
full processing pipeline
and study differentially expressed genes
using
such methods like dec 2 and edge r
this will allow us to find relationships
in the data
and identify significant genes that are
associated with cancer types
or stages we will learn about gene set
enrichment analysis
pathways activated or deactivated in
various tumors
and we will also speak about pathway
deregulation and the effect that many
subtle changes can have
on this condition these pathways will
give us insight
into the biology of tumor development
and how it interacts
with the microenvironment we will also
learn about the cancer genome atlas
finding data learning how to navigate
the genome data commons portal
and download multi-omics datasets with
clinical information about
samples we will also look at cancer
studies using patient-derived cell lines
where effective treatment can be derived
by looking at
profiles at the molecular basis we'll
also speak about the role big data plays
in biomedical research
as well as its clinical applications
where data from biopsies
is used to diagnose patients into novel
types of cancer
we will take samples from the liver
heptacellular carcinoma tcga project
and see how various clinical data
available for those patients can be used
in the analysis of gene and microrna
expression
the program will leverage our top-rated
online tutorials with smart tracking of
activity and curated data sets designed
for a great learning experience
you will also learn about methods of
dealing with data
in r and python and leverage our big
data analysis tools
where you can analyze huge omics data
sets without any technical background
in bioinformatics and without any
limitations of your personal
infrastructure
at the end of the program participants
will receive a certificate of
participation
in the previous programs many of the
participants completed the coursework
and continued on to leverage the
information they gained from the course
in their own research and clinical
applications
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand
diagnose and treat cancer we welcome you
to join this program
and learn about the bioinformatics
component for precision oncology